este es un ejemplo de un curso de
preparación para grado escolar en este
caso es preparación para sexto grado hay
un par de cosas interesantes aquí
primero puedes ver que el curso está
dividido en unidades como todos nuestros
cursos y el diseño de estas unidades
corresponde estrechamente al de las
unidades de sexto grado así puede usarse
en dos formas diferentes el curso de
preparación para sexto grado por ejemplo
puede utilizarse al comenzar el sexto
grado de manera que los estudiantes
puedan llenar todas las lagunas que
pudieran tener hasta antes de sexto
grado y después podrían trabajar en el
curso de sexto grado o puede hacerse al
mismo tiempo por ejemplo si dentro del
curso de sexto grado los estudiantes
están trabajando en la unidad de razones
tasas y porcentajes esta unidad que está
aquí en preparación para sexto grado se
puede utilizar para asegurarse de que
los estudiantes tienen todos los pre
requisitos para esta unidad ahora ya que
la mayoría de los estudiantes de sexto
grado tendrán algunos dominios y con
serán muchas de las habilidades del
curso de preparación para sexto grado lo
que nosotros recomendamos es que
comiencen con el desafío de curso al
tomar el desafío de curso los
estudiantes tendrán una oportunidad de
mostrar lo que ya saben y también de
identificar las lagunas que puedan tener
si a los estudiantes les está yendo bien
en el desafío de curso pueden continuar
con él tendrán diferentes ejercicios
cada vez y podrán avanzar rápidamente en
el curso de preparación para grado
escolar pero por supuesto si necesitan
llenar lagunas entonces pueden ir a las
unidades correspondientes por ejemplo
pueden ir a esta unidad y tener más
práctica enfocada en habilidades en
estos temas que aún no han dominado
incluso dentro de una unidad también
tienen herramientas como nuestras
pruebas de unidad que pueden ver aquí y
que de manera similar a los desafíos de
curso acelera el avance en lo que ya
conocen y también identifica lagunas en
lo que aún no saben
esperamos que todos disfruten los cursos
de preparación para grado escolar yo
solo use el de sexto grado como ejemplo
es una manera de asegurar que los
estudiantes en el grado en el que estén
no tengan esas lagunas con esta
herramienta podrán llenarlas y continuar
a su propio ritmo